Speaker 1: Last night during a live stream
that we were doing covering the latest news,
Jason Whitlock appeared on The Tucker Carlson
show. Jason Whitlock is his background is as a
sports journalist, but he's become kind of like a
Christian right wing nut commenting on politics.
And his entire appearance on the Tucker Carlson
show lasted under 3 minutes. And basically,
Tucker Carlson just teed up Jason Whitlock to go
on a very strange anti-transgender word salad,
which Tucker Carlson seemed to absolutely love.
This is quite literally insanity. This it sounds
like a crazy person talking. Listen to this.
Speaker 4: Beware all euphemisms. There are
always a cover for lying and misdeeds and gender
affirming care. That's a phrase you're seeing
everywhere, including conservative media, to their
great shame. What is gender affirming care? Well,
it's castrating children. It's exactly what it is.
And it's become finally or it's becoming illegal
in some states. But of course, activists
are trying to circumvent the law, the law,
the rule of law. So the person behind the site or
the Twitter feed libs of Tick Tock just unearthed
evidence of a drug smuggling operation aimed at
young children. Lipstick. Tick Tock found this
online post from someone called Eli Erlich. He
says he's a PhD student at UC Santa Cruz. Quote,
If anyone needs hormones, you can't get access.
Message me. Erlich wrote, I have a network with
years of extra doses.
Speaker 1: Now understand
the right is getting a lot of mileage from
anti-trans rhetoric. If you looked at if
you watched the clips from CPAC a couple of
weeks ago in Texas, the biggest applause lines
and standing ovations were for overtly
homophobic and transphobic assertions,
and that's why they're all picking up on it.
Speaker 4: Now, look said he wants to send
these drugs to quote trans youth. Now, that's a
crime, of course, but needless to say, the DOJ has
refused to investigate. Jason Whitlock is the host
of Fearless. He joins us today to assess what's
going on. So the DOJ. There is an effort to give
drugs illegally to kids that will castrate them.
But the Department of Justice is not interested.
Speaker 3:
No, they're not interested because anything that
has to do with gender identity, anything that has
to do with diversity, equity and inclusion,
they're all for and Instagram to go really
big picture here. But but and I've said this
before, but all of this to me is just satanic.
Speaker 1: But that's right. Yeah. This is
Satanism. It's absolutely. I'm sorry. It's
not Satanism. It's the work of the devil is what
Jason Whitlock believed. What a great analysis
on a major cable network.
Speaker 2: Targeting.
Speaker 3: Of young people and children that
are very impressionable at a very early age.
And now we've got someone trying to sell
them puberty, blockers or hormones that
will change their identity. And it all goes
back to this country was founded by people
who believed our rights came from God.
Speaker 1: If they believed that. They also
believed that that belief should have nothing
to do with civil government, which is that
little detail Jason Whitlock leaves out.
Speaker 3: And when I look at the left,
they want to disrupt that founding principle that
this is a country founded on biblical principles.
Speaker 1: What he means is the left
wants separation of church and state
as the founders wanted as well.
Speaker 3: They want to disrupt all of that. And
what we're going through right now, Tucker, is a
process called sifting, and it's in the Bible. One
of the last things Jesus said to his disciples.
Speaker 1: Luke, this is supposed to be an
analysis about policy. Understand the insanity,
and Tucker looks confused. But Tucker likes this.
This is supposed to be an analysis about policy.
And he's talking about sifting in the Bible.
Speaker 3: Chapter 22, verse 31, he tells Peter,
he calls him Simon, says the devil wants to sift
through. The sifting process is separating us.
It's all these different identities that they've
invented in our lifetime cisgender, nonbinary.
You're a Republican, you're black, you're white,
you're gay, you're lesbian. You're this year that
we're all being separated and our founders saw us
as all coming from one creator.
Speaker 1: It's really funny when the
people espousing the divisive rhetoric bemoaned
that the country is divided. It's a real irony.
Speaker 3: And even for nonbelievers, that
founding work for all of us. But as we're
being separated like wheat, where that's why
there's so much divisiveness in this country.
Speaker 4: Just feel like the only
person who would say that on TV
and we're grateful that you did good.
Speaker 1: So what what courage it took
for Jason Whitlock to show up on Tucker's show
and give us this bizarre, anti-trans religious
nutter word salad. But imagine watching
this episode last night and thinking, wow,
Jason Whitlock really nailed it. Sadly, there
are millions of people who will watch that
segment and say, this guy really speaks the
truth. And that's a very, very scary thing.